[Music]
good to see all of you you see a quote
up there by Niels Bohr one of the
founding figures of quantum mechanics
anyone who thinks they can talk about
quantum mechanics without getting dizzy
hasn't yet understood the first word of
it now why would that be what did Niels
Bohr mean by that well basically he
meant that we all have a good intuition
for classical physics right and by that
I mean you know if I was to take any
little object right give it a catch nice
did a one-handed catch right there
throws a little bit further back if you
go two for two
no we're still we're one for two they're
still back in the Dark Ages here we go
you have that one over there good right
now each one of the people who caught so
they'll be the two of you over here it's
a really a really evolved human being no
you see when we when we were out there
in the savanna trying to survive right
we needed certain skills we needed to be
able to know where to throw a spear how
to throw a rock to get the next meal we
needed to dodge some animal that was
running toward us and therefore we
learned the basic physics of the
everyday macroscopic so-called classical
world we learned that intuitively and
that's why when I throw an object you
don't have to go through some elaborate
calculation to figure out the trajectory
of that stuffed animal you just put out
your hand and catch it right it's built
into our our being but that's not the
case when we go beyond the world of the
everyday if we explore the world say of
the very small which is what we're gonna
focus on here tonight
we don't have experience in that domain
we don't have intuition in that demand
in fact were it the case that any of our
distant brethren way in the past if they
did have some quantum mechanical
knowledge and they sat down to think
about electrons and probability waves
and wave functions and
that sort they got eaten there change
didn't propagate right and therefore we
have to use the power of mathematics and
experiment and observation to peer
deeper into the true nature of reality
when things are beyond our direct
sensory experience and that's what
quantum mechanics is all about it's
trying to describe what happens in the
micro world in a way that's both
accurate and revealing and the thing to
bear in mind is even though our focus
here tonight will really in some sense
be in the micro world the world of
particles we are all collections of
particles so any weirdness that we find
down there in the micro world in some
sense it has an impact even in the macro
world and maybe suppressants will
discuss but it's not like there's a
sharp divide between the small and the
big we are big beings made of a lot of
small things so any weirdness about the
small stuff really does apply to us as
well and in this journey into the micro
world the world of quantum mechanics we
have some of the world leading experts
to help us along to figure things out
and let me now bring them on stage
joining us tonight is a professor of
philosophy at the University of Southern
California who spent 22 years at the
University of Oxford as a student
researcher and faculty member he is the
author of a book on the Everett
interpretation of quantum mechanics out
of the emergent multiverse please
welcome David Wallace
also joining us tonight is a professor
of chemistry at the University of
California Berkeley co-director of the
Berkeley quantum information and
computation center and faculty
scientists at Lawrence Berkeley National
Laboratory she's a fellow of the
American Physical Society and a
recipient of awards from the Burgman
Sloan & Alexander von Humboldt
foundations
please welcome Kay burr Geetha wailing
our third participant is the professor
of physics at the University of British
Columbia a simons investigator and a
member of the Simons Foundation it from
cubed collaboration
he was a Canada Research Chair in a
sloan foundation fellow and was awarded
the canadian CA PCRM medal to
theoretical mathematical physics in 2014
please welcome mark my mom's dog our
final participant is a professor of
theoretical physics at Utrecht
University in the Netherlands and winner
of the 1999 Nobel Prize in Physics for
work and quantum field theory that lay
the foundations for the standard model
of particle physics one of the greatest
minds of our era
please welcome Gerard at toast
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so subject is quantum
mechanics and part of the evening will
involve some challenge to the
conventional thinking about quantum
mechanics and so before we get into the
details I thought I would just sort of
take your temperature get a sense of
where you stand on quantum mechanics is
it in your mind a done deal it's
finished we completely understand it is
it a provisional theory is it something
which a hundred years from now we're
gonna look back on with a quaint smile
how do they think that that's how things
work so so David your view well I didn't
think we fully understand it yet I think
it has a lot of debts left to plumb and
who knows it might turn out to a place
but right at the minute I think we don't
have either empirical or theoretical
reason to think that anything will take
its place good Fergie - I think it's
fair to say there may be here to stay
you said you need to stay they may be
extensions and modifications there may
be something more complete but this will
still be part of it okay mark yeah so
there's a there's a frontier in quantum
mechanics that I work in and this is the
frontier it's like the Wild West of
theoretical physics where we're trying
to combine quantum mechanics and gravity
and we need to do that to understand
black holes and hopefully eventually
understand the Big Bang and and there
there's there's a lot to do and we don't
know if we're gonna have to modify
quantum mechanics or it'll all be the
same quantum mechanics but all the way
down right now your art you have unusual
views
well yes I could spend the rest of the
evening explaining them yes but to my
mind quantum mechanics is a tool a very
important mathematical tool to calculate
what happens if you have some underlying
equations and to tell telling us how
particles and other small things behave
we know the answer to that question the
answer is quantum mechanics but you
don't know the question that's still
something good so sort of a jeopardy
issue you know the American rapper
all right so just a quick overview we're
gonna start with some of the basics of
quantum mechanics just to sort of make
sure that all of us are more or less on
the same page well then turn to a
section on something called the quantum
measurement problem something weird
quantum entanglement as in the title of
the program will then turn to issues of
black holes space time and quantum
computation which will take us right
through to the end all right so just to
get to the the basics of quantum
mechanics the story of course began more
or less in the way that I started you
know we understood the world using
classical physics in the in the early
days way back to the 1600s and then
something happened in the early part of
the 20th century where people like you
know we started with Newton of course
then we move on to people like Max
Planck Albert Einstein what what drove
the initial move into quantum physics I
think it was really just pushing really
hard at classical mechanics as it went
down into the the scale of atoms and the
structure of atoms and just finding that
structure snapped and broke that trying
to use classical mechanics to understand
how hot things got or how electrons went
round atoms without collapsing into the
nucleus in all those places we had a
series of hints that something was amiss
in in our classical physics yes and it
took I guess most of 30 years for those
hints to coalesce into a into a coherent
theory but that here in theory then
became a not not really just a single
physical theory but a language for
writing physical theories be being
theories of particles or fields maybe
some days and gravity and that language
was more or less sort of solid by I
guess about 1930 yep it's it's actually
quite remarkable that it only took that
number of years to develop a radically
new way of thinking about things and
Richard Fineman who is of course a hero
of all of us also known to the public
famously said that there is one
experiment we could go through the whole
history of everything that you describe
with the ultraviolet catastrophe and
photoelectric effect and all these
beautiful experiments but the double
slit experiment luckily for us in having
a relatively brief conversation allows
us to get to the heart of this new idea
where it came from this actually is the
the paper on in some sense the double
slit experiment the first version
Davisson and Germer and I'll draw your
attention to one thing you see the word
accident and this is just a footnote but
in the old days people would actually
describe the blind alleys that they went
down in a scientific paper but as
science progressed we were kind of
taught no no don't ever say what went
wrong let me talk about what went right
but here was an old paper and indeed
this experiment emerged from an accident
in the laboratory of Bell Labs they were
doing a version of this experiment they
turned the intensity up too high some
glass tubes shattered and when they
redid the experiment unwittingly they
had changed the experiment to something
that was actually far more interesting
than the experiment that they're
initially carrying out so so just to
talk about what this experiment is in
modern language so David again just just
what's the basic idea of the double slit
experiment so you take a source of well
the particles of any kind but let it be
light for instance you shine that light
as a narrow beam on a screen it has two
gaps in it and you look at the pattern
of light behind the two gaps in the
screen it's exactly the slits are just
literally gaps in a black sheet of paper
and prints yellow but the lights going
through if light is a particle you'd
expect one sort of result on the far
side of the screen if light is a wave if
you might expect something different as
the light coming through one part of the
slit interferes with the light going
through the other part of the slit and
the weird thing about quantum - slit
experiment is that it seems in various
ways to be doing both of those things at
the same time good
so brigita if you can just take us
through a particle experiment to build
up our intuition so let's say we we
carried out the experiment that David
described but we don't start with
photons or electrons we start with with
pellet bullets or something so I think
they have a little
the animation that you could take us
through so what would we expect to
happen in this experiment so you have
the source of the pellets here in front
and it's pitching out the pellets and
some of them a go through the holes and
the ones that go through the hole they
sort of travels rectilinear straight
ahead as we might expect from our
classical intuition and we get two bands
of the back indicating the book the
pellets that went through the right slit
on the right and the left band is the
pellets that went through the left slit
now if I was that that's completely
intuitive right so this is the stuff
that our forebears would have known even
on the Savannah right now if we took the
size of the pellets and we dial them
down to a very small size before going
to your quantum intuition that you have
what would you expect naively to happen
if you simply dial down the size would
you expect there to be anything
different if you were this is a leading
question by the way did you just follow
me here the answer is I would you expect
anything different thing would you
expect anything good so they're not
exactly right
so here's what you would naively expect
would happen again
you've got the particles going through
the two slips so so mark tell us what
actually does happen not that I don't
think Brigitta could just to give us all
a little air time so it's oh of course
it's kind of wild the place where you at
least expect to see something on that
screen is exactly behind that big
barrier that's in the middle yep and and
somehow when you actually do the
experiment you see that actually that's
where most of the particles end up so
it's it's a no actually it's always
exactly the opposite and then you get
this weird pattern with other bands
going out and and and so you initially
would would stare at it and shake your
head and yeah wonder what you Doc so
will will will will analyze what that
means in just a moment but I you know we
often I don't know probably most
everyone in this audience has seen a
still image or an animation like this in
the discussion of quantum mechanics
and I thought it'd be kind of nice to
show you that it that
this actually happened it's not just
animation that an artist does so we're
gonna actually do the double slit
experiment for real right now and to do
that I'm going to invite a friend of
mine from Princeton University all Milan
can you wheel out if you would the
double slit experiment
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so what we have here is a
laser on this far side so this is our
source so actually we're doing this in
some sense opposite to the orientation
that we saw in the animation and we're
going to fire this laser which is
photons in essence and the photons are
going to go through a barrier that has
two openings in it it's harder to see
that of course mechanically but trust me
there's a barrier with two openings and
we're going to take a look at the data
that falls on a detector screen which in
the modern age is a more complicated and
somewhat finicky piece of equipment so
we're all sitting here on spill cos if
you if you speak any Guinness you know
exactly what I'm talking about right
there but hopefully this will this will
work out so so long let's let's why
don't we just actually see ambient noise
can we see a little bit of that first
but can we switch over to the input to
the screen all right so this is the
output from that device and now if we
actually turn on the laser and allow us
to collect all of the photons that land
there they're building up and there you
see what actually happened so this is a
result of this very device here and you
see it we have a you can see on the very
far left we see some of the photons are
landing then we get a dark region in
between then a bright a dark a bright a
dark a bright a dark and a bright and
dark even though this device over here
really is a barrier that has only two
slits in it so the animation that we
showed you actually does hold true in
real experiments and that then forces us
to come to grips with it to try to
understand what in the heck is actually
going on so thank you all on
so there we have it we have this the
situation in which we expect to get two
bands and we got more what does that
tell us where do we go from there
there's an existing bit of mathematics
that comes up with exactly that same
pattern but but it has nothing to do
with particles
it's the mathematics that you use to
describe waves water waves or other
kinds of waves yeah so can we see the
the the the animation has a single so
this is a warm-up to the problem where
we have water going through a single
opening it just tell us what we see
happening here that's right so you've
got you've got sort of a water wave a
wave front coming along and then just
that that slit acts as a bit of a source
for for this rippling wave going out in
a circular pattern and you see it's most
wavy at the at the place behind the slit
so the wall that's indicated by the
brightness there yeah and then if we go
on to a more relevant version for the
actual double slit experiment yeah so
now we've got that that same wavefront
but now there's there's two slits and
it's like there's two different sources
of waves like if you through two
different pebbles in the pond at the
same time and then what happens is that
they're both you're both creating
waviness but some places on the screen
the way from one is doing this and the
way from the other is doing this and
they kind of cancel out and but right
there in the middle what's happening is
that the way from the one slit is going
up right when the way from the other
slit is going up and then they do this
and you get a big wave and that's the
bright part but if you work out the
mathematics then the places that have
the big waves are exactly these bright
ones and that's just like we saw in the
in the double slit right for the
particles so as per our Burton is Markus
saying we now have a strange confluence
of two things the data that comes out of
the double slit experiment when done
with particles and something that seems
to have nothing to do with it
where we just have waves going through a
barrier with two
so the conclusion then is that there's
some weird connection between particles
and waves that's where that connection
comes from and and let's push that
further so I mean let's just drive home
how weird it should be that there is any
kind of connect yeah yeah so imagine I
do the two-slit experiment I cover up
one of the slits the effect completely
goes away I get a bit of spreading out
to the particles but I don't get that
interference I didn't get those bad much
as we saw with water going through
exactly exactly much even water going
through the single slit and much as you
see if your classical intuition about
particles if I cover up the other slit
exactly the same result it's only if I
have both slits open at the same time
the effect happens so it seems to be for
all the worlds if somehow something's
going through the first slit and
something else is going through the
other slit and between them they're
interacting to create this strange
effect and that's why it matters so much
that I can do this experiment of one
particle at a time if this was just the
mass of light going through no surprise
that sunlights going through the left
slit sunlights going through the right
slit the left-hand light the right-hand
light interferes but I can set this
stuff up so only one photon goes for
every hour and a half I still see the
effect it doesn't go down in this life
can we see that we think we have it and
then you might be thinking well maybe
each individual particle breaks in half
and half the parcel goes through one
slit and half the path will go the other
slit but again then you think you could
look then you think you'd be seeing half
strength detection x' yeah but that's
not what you see whenever you look each
time you send through the particle
through if you look where it is you see
the particle in one place one place only
so trying to reconcile those two
accounts of what's going on makes your
mind hurt yep exactly so so so we're
forced into as they would say not just
thinking that a large collection of
particles behaves like a wave which
maybe not wouldn't be that surprising
because water waves are made of h2o
molecules particles and therefore
they're kind of wavy but each individual
particle somehow has a wave-like quality
and and historically people struggled to
figure out what wave what kind of wave
what is it made of and what does it
represent if you have a wave associated
with a particle wave is spread out of
particles at a point and it was max born
in the 1920s who
came up with the strange idea of what
these waves are so Fergie - what what
are these waves telling us about
well the waves what we see is the
probability which is a square of the way
or where modulus of the wave but so
here's a way behind you so you said
probability yes in essence amplitude
this is an amplitude which will give us
a probability that if we take this
amplitude and look anywhere here with
some measuring device we will find with
some distinct probability after
measuring many times we'll find that
that's there's a definite probability of
the particle being there just as in the
double slit after sending many particles
through we found with a certain
probability they would all appear on the
left or all on the right
so in some sense vaguely where the wave
is big there's a high likelihood you're
gonna find the particle where the wave
is near zero there's a very small
probability that you're gonna find a
parent II it so any one particle that
would be in a place where the wave is
very very small now these are all just
pictures in the 1920s physicists were
able to make this precise so Schrodinger
wrote down an equation and I think we
and show you what the equation looks
like obviously you don't need to know
the math to follow anything that we're
talking about here but uh you know
Gerard you wanted to emphasize that
there is math behind this because your
experience has been that many people
missed that point so feel free to
emphasize absolutely quantum mechanics
when we talk about it there is a
temptation to keep the discussion very
fuzzy and so I get very many letters but
people who have their own ideas about
what's called mechanics is and they are
very good in reproducing fuzzy arguments
but they come without the equations or
the equations are equally fuzzy and
meaningless because the beauty of color
mechanics is the fundamental
mathematical here on certain situations
you can prove that if this equation
describes probabilities exactly as you
said yep before the
and then actually the equations and the
probabilities exactly the way
probabilities are supposed to be handled
except of course when two waves
reinforce each other the probabilities
become four times as big other than
twice as big but another shot spots the
waves annihilate the probabilities and
so for me this becomes zero
where are the waves vanishing so with
all this hangs together in a
fantastically beautiful mathematical
math math is one thing experiment is
another so how do you how would you test
the theory that only gives rise to more
probabilities of one outcome or another
how would you go about trying to
determine if it's right or it's wrong
yeah sorry it's like it's it's like if
you gave me a coin and you said you know
is this is it this is a probabilistic
thing you flip it it's gonna be heads
half the time and tells half the time
and and and I want to check that I don't
I don't trust you for I know why that
would be but I'm not as well so I just I
just I just flip the coin you know a
hundred thousand times or whatever a lot
of pay hands
if I want to be if I'm more sure I want
to be them where I flip it so maybe I
did I do a ten times I get four and six
and I maybe I'll flip it a hundred times
and then I get forty-eight heads and
fifty-two tails so I can basically just
repeat the experiment a whole bunch of
times and if I have a very precise
prediction from those quantum mechanics
equations to tell me exactly how often I
should expect to get one result versus
another though I think we have given a
little schematic what did we see how the
luck right so we're doing there there's
our wave that's describing the the state
of the particle the thing without a
definite location
now we're mentioned we're setting that
up a whole bunch of times and measuring
where the particle is each time and
these X's are showing the results of our
measurement that's like flipping a coin
and get a target so there's all these
possible locations and what we see is
that after a while the pattern of how
often I get one place versus another
place it's matching up to that
expectation given by the boy the blue
curve by this wave that's right so we
can't predict the outcome of any given
run of the
experiment but over time building up the
statistics we believe the theory if they
align with the probability profile given
by this wave whose equation we showed
you and that is what works out the shape
of the wave in any given situation and
just to bring this full circle if we
look at the double slit experiment in
this wave-like language now think of the
electron or the photon as a wave it goes
through it interferes like water waves
going through the two openings and
therefore you have an interference
pattern on the screen which is telling
you where it's bright it's very likely
that you'll find the particles where
it's dark it's unlikely where it's black
there's zero chance of finding the
particle there and therefore you run
this experiment with a lot of particles
and they're going to primarily land in
the bright regions they're gonna land
somewhat in the gray or regions and
they're not going to land at all in the
black regions and indeed that's exactly
what we showed in the experiment that we
ran with the double slit just a moment
to go and that's why we believe these
ideas so that's in some sense really the
the basics of quantum mechanics
classical physics particle motion is the
intuitive one described by trajectories
in quantum physics the particle motion
is somewhat fuzzier it's got this
probabilistic wave-like
character and the curious thing about a
wave is sort of a wave of probability if
the wave is spread out it means there's
a chance the particles here chance that
it's here a chance that it's here and
therefore the wave embraces a whole
distinct collection of possibilities all
at once
that in some sense is really the
weirdness of quantum mechanics so that's
the basic structure and now we're gonna
move on to our next chapter where we're
going to dig a little bit deeper we'll
talk about measurement and also
entanglement
[Applause]
they're checking the electron microscope
and the winner is number three in our
quantum finish no fair you change the
outcome by measuring it neither we have
a very sophisticated audience or you
just love you to Rama I'm not sure which
but-but-but-but
this is part of the issue that we now
want to turn to which is if you have a
quantum setup how do you how do you move
from this probabilistic mathematics
saying that the electron say could be
here or here or here with different
probabilities to the definite reality
that mark was described when you
actually do an experiment you find the
electron here or here or here you never
find anything a mixture of results so we
want to talk about how we navigate going
from the fuzzy probabilistic
mathematical description to the single
definite reality of everyday experience
and this is something that many
physicists have contributed to over the
years
again Niels Bohr we had a quote from him
early on and he certainly viewed as
really one of the founding pioneers of
the subject but let's now try to go a
little bit further with our
understanding of going from the math to
reality and we're gonna follow in in for
this part of the program it really Anil
Niels Bohr is footsteps and something
called the Copenhagen approach to to
quantum physics so David can you just
begin to take us through what what was
you know the ideas of collapse of the
wavefunction in technical language what
are those ideas all about Scylla clear
this way I've got my probability wave
which is sort of humped let's say just
for one particle it's humped over here
and it's humped over here so there's
kind of two ways I could think about
that you might say there's an N way in
an all way so I could think of it as
saying that the particle is here and the
particle is here or you could think of
it as saying or the particle is here all
the particles here and the problem is I
kind of need to use both to make sense
of quantum mechanics or so it seems so
if I try to explain the two
that experiment I have to think in the
end way to start with I have to think
the particles going through this slit
and it's going through this slit because
if it's just going through this slit or
it's going through this slit I could
close one of the slits and it wouldn't
make a little difference but then as
soon as I look where the particle is
suddenly the and way of talking stops
making sense because it doesn't seem
we'll come back to this it doesn't seem
as if I see the particle here and the
particle here it seems as if now I need
the or way of thinking so what came out
of the ideas of Bohr and Heisenberg and
they're acting people in the 20s and 30s
was well there must be some some new bit
of physics some way in which that
Schrodinger equation we saw earlier
isn't the whole story so suddenly the
wavefunction stops being peaked here and
here and it jumps it collapses let's see
a quick picture of that collapse so if
we have a probability wave here and this
is the and description in your language
it could be in these variety of
different locations and I now undertake
a measurement and I take that
measurement and it collapses to the or
way it's only at one of those suddenly
education and the mess the wavefunction
is gone and now if I turn away and I'm
stopped measuring it melts back into the
probabilistic description and we're back
to a language that feels quite
unfamiliar with the particle is in some
sense at all of these locations
simultaneously now the issue that you
raised is you said look we're gonna have
to have some other math to make this
happen so so so first if if we just use
the Schrodinger equation this beautiful
equation that is written down would that
be enough to cause a wave to undergo
that kind of transformation nice and
spread out and now collapses to one
location where the particle is found can
the Schrodinger equation do that for us
Brigitta
no no no that means no right it means
yes okay so like I said Gerard has
distinct views which are which are
spectacular interesting we're gonna come
to those in just a moment but let's now
follow the history of the subject where
going to just follow our nose and we
look at the equation that we have in it
and it doesn't do it so so what then do
we do to to get out of this this impasse
and to make this impasse even a little
bit more compelling I'm going to take
you through one version of this story
that I hope will make the conundrum as
sharp as it can be and then we'll try to
resolve it so I'm going to take you
through a little example over here where
we have say a particle somewhere in
Manhattan and let's imagine that the
probability wave makes the particle
location peak at the Belvedere Castle in
Central Park
just just randomly chosen but that would
mean as if somehow I had some measuring
device that could work out where the
particle is experimentally observational
II indeed it would reveal that the
particle is at that location the waves
is sharply peaked at that spot and
therefore all the probability is focused
right there that's quite a
straightforward situation imagine we do
the experiment again and the probability
wave has a different footprint let's say
it's way down there at Union Square if
you follow the same experimental
measurement procedure and you go about
figuring out through your observation
where the particle is you find indeed
there it is Union Square the conundrum
is the issue that David was speaking to
where we now have a situation where we
don't have one peak but two now it's
sort of like the particle is at the
Belvedere Castle and in Union Square and
that's puzzling because if you go about
looking at the observation what do you
think will happen here well the naive
thing is your detector kind of doesn't
know what to do it sort of caught
between the particle is at Belvedere
Castle and it's at Union Square but the
thing is nobody has ever found a
detector well I should say nobody who is
sober has ever
found a detector that does this right
this is not what we experienced in the
real world so this is the issue that we
have to sort out because that naive
picture is not borne out by experience
and I think many people here and many
people in the community have thought
about this you in particular David
believe that you you have the solution
it has a long historical lineage but why
don't you tell us a little bit about the
approach that you think resolve this
okay to start by reminding ourselves
what what's the problem with just saying
that the wavefunction suddenly jumps to
being in Belvedere or Union Square and
the problem is really just that we have
to modify the equations of physics at
every level to handle that and Jake
Schrodinger equation just does not let
that happen and to put it mildly we've
got quite a lot of evidence for that
structure of physics and for a whole
bunch of reasons
you know actually trying to change the
physics to make that sudden collapse of
the wavefunction physical and not I'm
not just as Jared was putting it not
just a sort of fuzzy talk is a really
really difficult technical problem but
you could say that we have to do that
because later I'm saying it doesn't seem
we have a see a particle here and here
at the same time and I think Brian's
joke is about right as to what our
intuition is about what it will be like
to see a particle here and here at the
same time it would be like like being
really drunk like seeing double but
here's the thing if you want to work out
what some physical process would be like
and my looking at a particle is just one
more physical process turns out
intuition is not a very good way to
predict what happens so how do we ask
what would it really be like to see a
particle that's here in here at the same
time well what if the physics say I'm
just one more measurement device and the
physics says something like this if I
saw the particle here I'd go into a
state that you might call a seeing the
particle here state if I look at the
particle there and then I go into what
you call are seeing the particle there
state if it's in both states at the same
time then I go into both states at the
same time so being a little loose for a
minute then I now in the state seeing
the particle here and see
particle there and if I tell Brian where
the particle is because I'm sure he's
fascinated Brian's now in the David says
it's here and David says is there and I
hold all the ins have to listen to me
say this you're now all in the it's here
and it's there state at the same time
and the reality is that even if I don't
tell you this uncontrollable effects
spread outward and so before you know it
the whole planet the whole solar system
is in a particle was seen here and
particle was seen here at the same time
stain and if those two states don't
interact with each other they that
they're that they're way too complicated
to do the sorts of interference
exponents we were doing with the
two-slit you come to a two-slit
experiment on the whole planet and so
for all intents and purposes what the
quantum theory is now describing is two
sets of goings on each of which looks
for all the world like the particle
being in a definite place and that's
where the terminology of this way of
thinking about quantum mechanics comes
about the many worlds theory it was Co
Everett who said look if you just take
quantum mechanics seriously you'll lead
to this crazy sounding idea of there
being many parallel goings on at the
same time every time you make a quantum
measurement but the thing I want to
stress here is it's not that we say
quantum mechanics is weird but let's
bring in an even weirder idea out of the
realm of science fiction to make it even
stranger it's what whatever it was
saying and what people have pushed his
idea since then have been trying to make
precise is the idea that the quantum
theory itself that Schrodinger equation
itself when you take it really seriously
tells you that not at the fundamental
level not at the level of the
microscopic physics but at the level
that we see around us in the everyday
then physic then the physics is
describing many goings on at the same
time the look the the quantum
probability wave carries on being an and
wave all the way up so you're talking
about many many universe many universes
so this is where this idea of parallel
universes or many worlds come from so an
example that we were looking at there
would be say if you were undertaking
this measurement there'd be you seeing
the particle at Belvedere you seeing at
at Union Square and as you said once you
tickle eight that we're all hearing it
and we're all going along with you in
one universe and another exactly so
that's one approach to trying to
disambiguate a situation in which the
quantum mechanics has many possibilities
you're saying no no it's not just that
one of them happens they all happen they
all just happen to happen indistinct
universe right and weirdly that's a
conservative idea I mathematically
conservative math and that's actually a
vital point so so and this is an idea
that's hard to communicate to a general
audience I'm sure many of you are
technically trained but those who aren't
if you stare at equations of quantum
mechanics and just take them at face
value this seems to be where the math
takes you but is that convinced so it's
are you guys convinced they're getting
you there are alternative perspectives
but what I don't you like this one I
like it I think it's fascinating I think
it's wonderful yeah let's bring in some
information so how much information are
we going to keep so this many-worlds
hypothesis would say that we're keeping
every single piece of information but if
we we have a measuring device and then
the measuring device is interacting with
an environment and the environment of
outside is also playing a role it's also
affecting the measuring device and all
these many many options measurements
that can be recorded by the measuring
device if the environment which is
interact with that measurement device is
interacting the measuring device and
produces many more outcomes and yet then
we throw in producing many much more
information but then we throw all of
that information of the environment away
then we're left with something which
reduces to just the one one of these
options so you're talking technical
language of what's called decoherence
I'm introducing this technical term that
the coherence of the wave function this
the preservation of these so your belief
is that if we don't focus just on a
simple particle itself but in take into
account how it talks to and interacts
with the full environment you feel that
that's enough to solve the conundrum
well I'm
there's also mathematics
yes don't know either so this is another
perspective I'm not saying we don't know
it which is one but this is a very
strong argument for saying why we don't
actually experience many many what's
your view on the mini yeah I mean I I
think it's what what you were describing
I mean it's basically just going all in
on the Schrodinger equation saying okay
we've got this beautiful equation it
applies to the the atomic world let's
take it seriously and and just if we
believe in it then I mean you not only
kind of understand through the
mathematics there that at the local
level you would have effectively get
something like collapse if you look at
just a part of the description of the
system but but then you know the only
thing is that in the end it's a little
bit disturbing philosophically that
there's a maybe a part of the wave
describing the universe where you know I
I'm I'm a football player or then that
question of well why why did what is our
experience yes in that picture of many
worlds is there is there some way to
just to understand you know why does
we're just experiencing one thing and
Detroit have a no I know that you gonna
take us somewhere else when you ask me
about this question what the
wavefunction you were nodding I was
supposed to not know and I know that yes
[Laughter]
the point is this that quantum mechanics
today is the best we have to do the
calculation but the best we have doesn't
mean that the calculations it extremely
accurately correct so according to the
equations we see we get this many worlds
I agree with that statement but I don't
agree with the statement that quantum
mechanics is correct so we have to
accept all these other universes for
being real no recalculations incomplete
there is much more going on that it
didn't take into account and then again
you can mention the environment other
things that you forgot so we are so used
in physics
the unimportant secondary phenomena can
be forgotten he just leaves about very
dated calculation for granted but if you
do that you don't get for certain which
universe you are in you get a
superposition of different universes it
doesn't mean that the real outcome that
that what's really happening is that
universe splits into a superposition of
different universes
it means our calculations inaccurate and
it could be done better and that doesn't
mean that our theory is wrong but that
we made simplifications we made lots of
simplifications instead of describing
the real world we split up the real
world in what I call templates all the
particles you talk about and not to view
particles they are just mathematical
abstractions of a real particle we use
that because it's the best we can do
which is perfect it's by far the best we
can do so in practice that is just fine
but you just have to be careful in
interpreting your result the result does
not mean that universe splits in many
other universes news up means yes this
answer is the best answer you could get
now look at the amplitude of the
universe these universities you get out
the one with the biggest amplitude is
most likely the rightest answer but all
the other answers could be correct I
could be wrong if we add more details
which we are unable to do today perhaps
also tomorrow you also will be unable to
do it exactly precisely correctly so we
have to do with what we've got today and
what we've got today is an incomplete
theory we should know better but
unfortunately we are not given the
information that we need to do a more
precise calculation that precise
calculation does show wave functions
that do not pick a different point at
the same time like you have in Manhattan
that this address that address and we
are a superposition know in the real
world to be another in a superposition
because the real world takes
single phenomenon into account and you
cannot ignore what happens in the
environment and so on if if you ignore
that then you get all this case
superposition phenomena if you would do
the calculation with infinite precision
which nobody can do if you calculate
everything that happens in this room and
way beyond and take everything into
account you would find a wave function
which doesn't do that you would find one
which Peaks only at the right answer and
it gives zero at the wrong answer now
this this view this thing is so unstable
right that them the most minut in
practice in your calculation gives you
these phony signals that say maybe
universe and this may be university that
maybe it is that only if you do it
precisely correctly then you get only
one answer yeah but now that that
resonates obviously with an idea that
goes all the way back to Einstein yes I
think I would agree this such such yeah
I think they think that it would - maybe
it's not - maybe yes but anyway it is to
me it sounds like an Einsteinian
attitude that no nature's absolute God
doesn't gamble the gamble is in our
calculation because we can't do any
better let's take a step back and see
why Einstein came to this conclusion
that quantum mechanics is incomplete
which takes us to the next strangeness
of quantum mechanics which is something
called quantum entanglement so this is
an idea that has a long history in
physics that would not call entanglement
what you're about to talk about one but
rather the characteristic trade of
quantum mechanics the one that enforces
its entire departure from classical
lines of thought so so here's again one
of the founding pioneers of the theory
whose thought about this notion that
we're about to describe as the key
element that distinguishes it from our
intuition or a classical way of thinking
and as we'll see it quickly in the hands
of Einstein takes us to a viewpoint that
aligns really with what Gerrard was
saying and that comes most forcefully in
a paper from 1935 a date that's good to
keep in mind
we're gonna come back to in just a
little bit where these folks write a
paper Einstein Podolsky and Rosen and we
can just this is actually a New York
Times article on it you see that the
they call the theory not complete much
as as Gerard was describing and it's
good to get a feel for for why it is
that they came to this conclusion and it
involves this idea of entanglement I'm
gonna like us to walk through that just
some of the key steps and it's good to
do it in a context of an example it's
not the example that Einstein and his
colleagues actually use but it's an
example having to do with the quality of
particles called spin so just to set it
up and then I'll let the panelists take
it from there when we talk about a
particle say like an electron it turns
out that has a characteristic called
spin you can think of it almost like a
top that's spinning around and roughly
speaking using classical language is to
get a feel for it if the spin say is
counterclockwise to say it's spinning up
if it's clockwise you say it's spinning
down and weirdly a particle can be in a
mixture of being both up and down using
your language of the end and only when
you measure the particle do you find
that it snaps out of that mixture and is
that in the in the case of the particle
Manhattan it was either at one location
or another here it's one spin or another
it's spinning down or up but it's
definite after you do the measurement
you never find it in between again you
can do a second measurement and say it
snaps out of this fuzzy haze and it's
spinning up and that's a quality of a
single particle that's well-known
in in quantum physics but entanglement
arises when you don't have one particle
but rather when you have two of them and
here's the weirdness that happens if you
do a measurement in this situation even
though each particle is 50% up or 50%
down you think they're completely
independent but you can set things up in
such a way that when you do a
measurement it's always the case that if
the one on the Left is up the one on the
right is down
they never are both up or both down and
we can go back to this story again do
another measurement and they can be as
far apart as you want and you
you find je that the left one is down
and the right one is up so they're kind
of locked together by a quantum
connection quantum entanglement which is
graphically we're representing by this
little yellow line over here now Gerard
was talking about incompleteness of
quantum mechanics what was Einstein's
view of what was going on here well
Einstein's view was that really what's
going on here is if you have particles
that the math says they're both spinning
up and spinning down at the same time if
you can look deeper to the deeper
structure that Gerard was referencing
you'd find that these particles always
have a definite spin they're not
actually going up and down
that's just mathematics they actually
have a definite spin and therefore if
you measure them and find that one is up
in the others down they were already
like that it's not as though there was
some long-distance connection or
communication going on and this is
what's known as quantum entanglement and
when I describe this to general audience
people often get the phenomenon yeah you
measure it here it's down to measure it
there it's up but then they always come
back to me and say but what's really
going on you know like but just tell
explain to me I said just did explain to
you what's going on that that's all
there is no no they say please tell me
like how could this be so so how should
we interpret this result so Einstein
says the way you interpret it is it was
like this the whole time nothing
surprising but then we try to do
experiments and see if that's the case
and and what happens so there's a famous
person that comes into the story who
john bell and and and so what does amar
what does bell blows Bell do for us I
mean I mean basically to put it simply
he finds that any kind of simplistic
Einstein like description where the
thing had the definite configuration
before we did that measurement it can't
explain the results so we say the
results you're talking about can't
observational that's right that's right
yes so he writes this this famous paper
what year is this 1964 I think this
think it's like 1964
writes his famous paper where he he
surprisingly is able to get at an
experimental consequence of an
Einsteinian view that things are
definitely up or down before you look
it's just the mathematics that's giving
this weird superposition quality and
then people go out and ultimately
starting say with John clauser and the
this must be the 70s and into 80s with
Alana spay they carry out the
measurement and they find as Mark was
saying that the Einsteinian picture
doesn't describe the actual data
so if Einstein were here I think you'd
have to conclude not necessarily that
quantum mechanics is complete but the
[ __ ] in the armor that he thought he
found isn't actually correct so George
what's your what's your because you're
coming at it from an Einstein Ian's view
how do you deal with they say this very
experiment may I just add one point
three first you can think of a classical
experiment is very simple but not
strange at all
think I take two marbles in a black box
sure one marble is ahead
the other one is green now I shake the
mobs as much I want
I put blindfold Li I put one marble in
one box and Alabama lamella box and I
bring these boxes light-years away from
each other as soon as somebody who sits
or a celestial model the earth and one
of my assembly on earth opens his box
and at the same time the guy on Mars
opens his box before they open the box
didn't know what kind of marble they had
in in there in the box also they had one
or was at the game oh you don't know the
soon as the one on earth opens box a
society they had marble instantly the
guy and Mars knows that he has the green
marble that information went much faster
than light but you also know all this is
nonsense because they knew it in advance
I did I had one red and one green marble
so what's the big issue no problem right
so the Bell experiment is fundamentally
different from this situation
in the sense that yes sir we do describe
you just probably sort of the
Einsteinian picture in science I would
say don't get worked up up tangle man
it's just like having to read marble or
blue sonic picking would walk but
perfectly well for the box with a head
Marvin Green Bible no sweat no yes
faculty we understand that situation no
no miracle at all but for the bell light
experiment the spinning particle you are
using in fact that the particle is a
quantum spinning particle and it's
spinning particle something very very
strange because it can either spin up or
spin down but then someone asked what
about spinning sideways if I not locate
the particle 45 degrees of 90 degrees
and they will say yes but that's a
quantum superposition but now if the one
person on earth looks at the particle in
a in spinning up the one of my series is
spinning down but then when the person
sees a patentable spinning sideways the
guy of my sees the part of spinning
Sciences in the other direction
right and sees it I was spinning up or
spinning down we still do in the
sideways direct but the well they both
look in the scientist erection again see
the spin opposite knobs and that is the
miracle yeah that is a thing which is
very very difficult to understand
classically I maintain but this is my
private opinion that you can explain it
but it is because this is where I sit
both have the same origin they both came
eventually form from an atom emitting
two spinning objects or two photons or
two electrons or something like that
which were entangled and so the
entanglement can be explained in terms
of correlations so that the initial
state was not that the pattern could be
doing just anything no there are
correlations all over the place this is
very very difficult to explain I would
even dare to try to go into Ivan and
have any depth but the answer lies in in
correlations do you think there is a way
out of this in I think there's a way out
but it's extremely non-trivial maybe
don't do it quite right you enter
mystified
that being mystified by the situation
yeah it's also extremely hard to make a
model that works that gives this
strange-looking phenomenon right so so
yes you have a problem but no I think
the problem has an answer but it's very
difficult and you have to work very hard
to make it make it or hang together
properly so that'll be in the footnote
to tonight's program you'll receive it
in your email so David your your your
view on entanglement is there is there a
mystery here or there's kind of mystery
and and it kind of links to our earlier
mysteries I mean looking this way
my my wave might my probability wave for
the for the two spinning particles you
can kind of describe as something like
half is this down up and half is this up
down and again we can ask this well do I
want to think about as an and or an or
do I want to fit do I want to say well
it's this or is this or do I somehow
have to say it's this and it's this now
if it's this or this
that's Jared's case that's not
mysterious at all and that's exactly
what Einstein and Podolsky and Rosen
hope was the case but what Bell's
results show us is that the the this all
this reading of entanglement just like
in some ways the the this slit all this
slit reading of the two slit experiment
would lead to experimental predictions
that don't pan out we can't at least
straightforwardly we can't make sense of
the experiments without seeing the
entangled system as being this and this
and now we're right back to the mystery
because understanding how it can be this
and this which seems to imply some sort
of deep connection between the two
systems where somehow saying everything
there is about this side and everything
there is about this side separately
doesn't tell you everything right that
weird reading seems compulsory right hmm
so so forgive you your view on this
should we fret about entanglement is it
I think I think I raised a very
important point with is that when one
talks about entanglement one should not
forget to say how the particles got
entangled yes and they get entangled
through an interaction
and I think to most physicists
entanglement is not so mysterious if we
think about it in those terms because we
so even in just atomic or molecular
terms so take the two electrons in the
helium atom in the ground state the
helium atom is if we were to separate
the two electrons we know we can't do
that because they're they're sitting on
top of each other but were you to be
able to take those two electrons and
pull them apart they would be in the
perfectly entangled pair but we know how
they got there because they had an
interaction that put them into a
particular electronic state and so if
you just randomly put two particles
together they would not be entangled
necessarily yeah to my mind though the
very fact that I don't care how you set
it up the fact that you can set it up
still still still makes me in Niels
Bohr's let me dizzy but but but yes I
agree that does mitigate it to some
extent but still it's so far outside of
common experience that it's that it's
still hard to grasp but for this
purposes let's assume entanglement is
real because now we want to move on to
think about how it manifests itself in
some unusual places like in the vicinity
of a black hole so that's the the next
thing that we're going to turn to and
for that extent let's move on to the
next section quantum mechanics and black
holes and we'll also begin with a little
clip
do you have a stray dog down there two
stray dogs all right so so black holes I
think most most people here are quite
familiar with their own but just again
to get us on the same page mark just
described what it would it's a black
hole yeah so that that comes out of I'm
Stein's picture of gravity and how the
space that we live in is not a sort of
passive background but it's dynamical it
can warp and Bend and it does that kind
of in response to the the mass and the
energy that's in the universe and them
the black hole is is the situation where
you take that to the extreme you have so
much matter it could be a gigantic star
at the end of its life when it's burned
up its fuel and then it starts to
collapse and as its getting denser and
denser it's warping the space more and
more through Einstein's picture and at
some point you you get a space of the
space-time it's warped so much that you
get the the thing we call a her eyes and
you get the point of no return where if
you go past that you can't get out you
can't send signals out light can't get
out and and that's our basic notion yeah
black hole there many puzzles about
black hole and some of them are right at
the forefront of research there's one in
particular that I want to focus on as it
will bring together these ideas of
entanglement and ultimately the
structure of space-time which is where
we'll get to in the next chapter which
is simply this if something falls into a
black hole what happens to the
information that it contained right so
to just be concrete imagine I was to
take out my wallet and throw it into a
black hole my wallet is all sorts of
information credit card information
OOP there it is they took it out of my
pocket they throw it into the black hole
it crosses over the horizon the edge
that mark was referring to and at least
in the in the non quantum in the
classical description it's just gone
right and and you can you can think that
the information is sort of maybe still
there it's just on the other side we
can't get at it unless we
if we do that their consequences we
can't come back out with the information
you know so that's so that's sort of the
the the classical story this becomes a
really big puzzle and a bigger puzzle
when we include quantum mechanics into
the story because of a result that was
due to a couple of very insightful
physicists one who you may not have
heard of one who you will have heard of
so back in the in the seventies jacob
bekenstein and also this fella over here
stephen hawking they began to apply
quantum ideas to two black holes and
found a surprising result
which is that black holes are actually
not completely black so anyone just to
jump in and and what is it that that
means or mark oh yeah so so so hawking
found when you when you start to apply
quantum mechanics to the the physics and
the vicinity of a black hole that there
are quantum effects that lead to the
black hole seeming to emit particles out
of it as a graph this is sort of a
quantum effect where where you you have
some something happening right at the
horizon of the black hole where where
what we would call virtual particle and
an antiparticle that they show a logical
is red that in oracle any particles blue
so this can happen in quantum mechanics
but because of the black hole horizon
the the particles end up going out and
and so what horrors fell in they went no
see those partners since weak and so you
leaving far away if we look at this
situation that's right so there we go so
so the black hole looks like it's
emitting stuff and it's actually losing
some of its mass so you see it's getting
smaller
Hawking get a detailed calculation to
show that it's it's behaving like an
object that's getting hotter and hotter
and hotter and and sort of we call it
evaporating more and more quickly and
ultimately disappearing so all of the
this information that might have been in
the black hole it's now it's now this
this this heat this thermal radiation
going out into space and all of this is
happening if I understand so you got the
edge of the black hole you got this
quantum process right at the edge that
we're familiar with particle
antiparticle sort of pops out of empty
space the difference is now with the
black hole there it can kind of pull on
one member of the pair it gets sucked in
the other just rushes out and that gives
rise to radiation flying outward and
that's what makes this this puzzle sharp
because if the wallet goes into the
black hole and then you have this
radiation coming out ultimately in
perhaps the black hole even disappears
through this everything that went in has
come out but if the radiation itself
doesn't have an imprint of the wallet
doesn't somehow embody the information
the information would be lost and
Hawking's calculation showed that it
should not matter what formed the black
hole you get exactly the same radiation
come with my wallet or whether it's a
refrigerator
chicken soup it all would sort of come
out the same the information is lost
now this disturbed your hard deeply yeah
very much so
but the statement you just made was only
about the evolution particle the hard
patterns form article a thermal spectrum
which means that they come out in a
completely fundamentally chaotic way but
it doesn't mean that they don't know how
a particle in what way to come out again
it's ponta mechanics but again there is
a theory underlying core mechanics which
is more precise and which should provide
the missing information and yes there
was missing information and yes your
wallet does leave an imprint on the
radiation coming out so can we show
across your wallet yes your wallet
carries a gravitation
field even though it's very light
compared to a planet or a star it does
have gravity that gravity is sufficient
to lead a very minut imprint on the
outgoing particle so we sort of see the
different here of my wallet on the edge
of the blackhole effect of this is that
the information gets stuck on their eyes
would you show that one again you to
come out again in the form of the Horten
particles right and this in principle
you can compute and and you find that
the culprit is the gravitation field of
your wallet that many people forget to
take it to account then you get a
tremendous problem you don't understand
how can it be that all these dollars in
your and carrot cards in the wallet and
that information gets out well no a
person that'll be able to to identify to
decompose an organization get back to
your water they won't be answered if
it's a shadow
you'll never find anywhere right even
the shadow still contains the
information right so people won't
actually be able to do this reconstruct
no but if principled just like with the
shredder and principle they would be
able to do that so there's an idea that
that that you developed also with Lenny
Susskind yeah which gives rise to what
we call the holographic principle the
holographic description again because if
information is stored on a thin surface
at the edge of the black hole it sort of
brings to mind a hologram which is a
thin piece of plastic which has edgings
on it when you illuminate it correctly
it yields a three-dimensional entity
here you've got information on this thin
two-dimensional surface which is able to
reconstruct the object that went in and
that's why this word holography is used
this is sort of a deep insight which has
been generalized people Gerard and Lenny
and others think that perhaps the right
way of thinking about the universe any
environment even right here on earth
there's a description where data exists
on a thin two-dimensional bounding
surface which would make us the
holographic projections using this
language
of this information that exists on a on
a thin surface that you wouldn't think
would even have the capacity to store
enough information to make it adequate
to describe all the comings and goings
in this three-dimensional realm
yes yeah I mean it just sort of sort of
pit pin down for a moment like why
should we have cared in the first place
that the information was lost we but by
assuming the information is not being
lost we've made our way to remarkable
new ideas and physics and I think
there's something a temptation to think
well you know maybe that's the wrong
lesson maybe what we should learn is
what information disappears sometimes
deal with it and I think we're Hawking
which is what Hawking said exactly
there's still there's still a minority
of people in physics who take that line
yeah and I think the deeper reason to
think why but Hawking doesn't take the
whole thing's mine and I think the
deeper reason to see why information
being lost is such a problem is goes
back to where we started the idea that
black holes are hot that everything else
in the universe we know that's hot has a
story to tell about why it's hard but
basically says it can be in zillions and
zillions and zillions of different
states and by statistically averaging
over all those states we get out the hot
behavior that's how thermodynamics is
grounded in microscopic physics for
every other hot thing in the universe if
information is lost forever in black
holes then black holes are hot for a
fundamentally different reason than why
everything else in the universe is hot
and this whole story about holography
and about information being preserved is
basically a bet and it seems to me a
very well motivated bet on the idea that
black holes are hot for the same reason
everything else is hot right right so so
again one way of saying that is when
when a black hole is radiating it's
radiating because in some sense stuff is
burning near the edge even though all
the matter that fell in is compressed at
the center and that's unfamiliar because
when a star burns it's burning at its
surface so the stuff responsible the
fuel is burning right where the
radiation is emitted but with a black
hole all of the fuel the mass is here
whereas the radiation is coming out over
here and that distinction might suggest
that it's a different kind of burning
but you're absolutely right we want all
the usual ideas of physics to work it
better be the same kind
burning and and that's what the approach
of holography provides for us and and
what I'd like to do now is if we can
jump actually to the next chapter just
because time is a little bit stored I
want to take this idea of entanglement
and and in mark yeah let me just
introduce that a little bit I mean yeah
one of the things you know hawking
hawking did his calculation in an
approximation where he didn't have a
theory that actually combined gravity
and quantum mechanics he was using bits
of quantum mechanics and Einstein's
theory and coming up with this result
that you lose information and now if
that were true it would it would it
would say that gravity and quantum
mechanics are incompatible you have to
change quantum mechanics somehow but in
quantum mechanics you never lose
information and and so this is why that
this this kind of this holographic
insight of Gerard and and others is so
important it sort of has given us a way
of avoiding Hawking's conclusions and
Hawking has accepted that and so this
this way there's now it's been for the
past 20 years we've got a way of doing
quantum gravity of combining gravity and
quantum mechanics and it uses this
holographic idea in in a completely
essential way and it was it was like it
was like that picture of the earth with
with the data around it it was it's kind
of like saying that our reality that we
experience this this gravitational
universe that we're we're in there's
kind of an underlying reality which you
can think of as those those bits those
ones and zeros on the surface
surrounding us and that you know that's
what Brian was referring to as the
hologram so so somehow if you want to
understand the quantum mechanics of a
system with say black holes and gravity
what you really want to do is understand
the quantum mechanics of that of that
hologram and not kind of directly try to
do the calculations like hawking did of
of the black hole there's a very
powerful come to you half a second just
to summarize that well it's a very
powerful dictionary in some sense you
now have two ways of describing a given
physical system you can describe it sort
of in the conventional way that we've
always thought about it as a
three-dimensional world that has comings
and goings or you have
alternative language if you want to make
use of it which is the physics that
takes place on this thin bounding
surface and sometimes that latter
description gives you insights that are
very difficult to obtain from the
traditional description and we're gonna
come to a version of that in just a
moment but yeah more clear perhaps by
realizing that whenever we saw something
into the black hole when you look at it
from the outside you will never see it
actually pass through the horizon yeah
it hangs around at the horizon so it
shouldn't be too surprising that that
information also hangs around at the
horizon yeah so can I just flush it out
for half a second so what you're saying
is if you look at how a black hole
affects the passage of time you find
that as a clock gets closer and closer
to the edge of a black hole the clock
ticks off time ever more slowly so if
you're watching this from very far away
the object is starting to go in slow
motion as it goes toward the edge of the
black hole it doesn't just immediately
go over the edge in fact it goes so slow
that would take an infinite amount of
time from your perspective for it to
actually fall over the edge but hangs
out there I think the clock is standing
still getting still but that day clock
asleep is showing your time that the
observer who goes mr. clock sees that oh
that's the time I'm going through the
horizon right but for the arts observer
that's the eternal time it never changes
anymore the other observation one can
make is it's a very elementary
calculation to find out how much how can
we put other kinds of information in
such a box take a box as a certainly
radius and let it miss track of the
simplicity and ask how much information
can I put in the box no matter what I do
so take a gas or take a liquid or take
dictionary so anything in a box when do
I get the maximum amount of information
you can calculate that about you find
this if you try to put more things in a
box that takes so much energy that those
things Eskil pedia that you try to put
in this box will automatically make a
black hole and what is the object it
contains the most informations you can
ever imagine it's the black hole it
always
wins right so the black hole is the
maximum there's no way no matter what
you put in the box with a given radius
to get more information in that box than
what fits on the surface and that's the
whole graphic principle information is
stored imaginal not 3-dimensional right
that is very strange so so that's why I
call it holography it is as if you know
we have a three dimension world but to
take a picture with the machinery of a
holography I don't have any no it is a
gamma which makes a picture and if you
look at the picture it looks like big
reconstructing the three-dimensional
object did you doubt this idea when when
you first really this is in discussions
of any Susskind the word holography came
up right but but I mean were you certain
that this was right when it popped out
or was it so strange that you were this
comes out with the calculation must be
told
counter intuitive yeah yeah it's like
saying our reality is not as real as we
think it is yeah right yeah which is
which is which for most of us is pretty
much question is what happened to did
the rest of the information the
three-dimensional information doesn't
disappear doesn't get lost our
space-time so let's take this whole
graphic idea and push it one step
further which yeah I mean we take it
seriously but before we get that because
there's one thing that we didn't discuss
that would be useful and it sits right
here which is something else that
happened in 1935 which is the idea of a
wormhole so if you can just take us
through what a wormhole is so the the
wormhole if you set to to solving
Einstein's equations to figure out well
what kind of geometries are possible for
space-time then there's there's a weird
thing that that comes out where you it's
like you have a black hole in an in an
empty universe and then there's this
entirely separate universe with another
black hole in the top on the bottom of
this picture yeah that's so that's
that's the space the flat part is the
space in one universe and then and then
this is like a black hole but it's not
you see it's connected down to the flat
part which is like the other universe
yep
and there's this physical geometrical
connection so if one person jumped into
the one black hole and the other person
jumped into the black hole at the bottom
they could potentially meet up inside
that wormhole
you know before being annihilated by
these it's sort of a tunnel connecting
these two that's right ie volunteering
god I'll pass yeah so you may recall I
said remember the Year 1935 that was at
einstein-podolsky-rosen which was the
entanglement that we've been discussing
this is also 1935 where it's Einstein
and Rosen so again two of the three
folks involved and he in in Einstein's
mind I think it's pretty clear and
correct me if you think otherwise I
don't think he thought there was any
connection between these two 1935
discoveries entanglement on the one hand
coming from quantum physics wormholes
coming from general relativity a
completely separate subject at the time
and and some of the work that you and
and embarrass of our other colleagues
have been pursuing is suggesting that
there's actually a deep connection
between yes really it's trillium amazing
so I think we'll sort of step through
that now works for you so we have a
little you can sort of walk us through
what we have so there so we're looking
at some kind of universe there's a black
hole in this universe and and then
what's on the outside is this this
hologram this is like the the actual
mathematical description you know in our
modern way of understanding so this red
around the outside has all of the
information that is telling us what kind
of geometry is in there that's our molar
motion that Suraj hologram on the
outside you've got that hologram in a
particular kind of physical
configuration and that's coding for the
fact that there's this black hole and
maybe some stars in there in the
space-time yep and then if we go on and
go to the second black hole in this
story so now now we've got two separate
black holes and basically that's going
to be encoded by some other information
so you change up the information and now
you've got two black holes yep and then
if we add to this story a certain kind
of entanglement say so so here what
did we turn that such situation into one
where you have a wormhole connecting
behind the two black holes and and the
remarkable thing is in order to do that
in the holographic set in the
holographic description in the outside
description what we actually you know we
we have to do something fundamentally
quantum mechanical what we had to do is
actually add in a whole bunch of
entanglement between different parts of
the hologram and that was what achieved
getting this they suggested summarizes a
deep and utterly stunning idea you're
saying that entanglement in the
holographic description the red
description is in the interior
description nothing but a wormhole
connecting to black holes
that's just which is just a sort of a
classical thing that would have been
covered by Einstein's kind of classical
understanding of gravity it's just a
geometrical connection saying you could
get from here to here and that property
is entirely according to this curling to
our current understanding due to quantum
entanglement between different parts of
the hologram and moreover if you you
find that you can actually generalize
this that it actually even holds without
a black hole in the space it'd take us
from here yeah so so I this is I guess
2009 I would I was thinking about that
it seemed crazy and then one of the
things that you that you realize if you
if you start reading about entanglement
and about just our our description in
these theories of just empty space is
that even when you're describing empty
space you still have entanglement in in
the hologram in the holographic
description there's lots of entanglement
and then and then you sort of asked
yourself well wait is if that
entanglement in the previous story was
creating a connection between the two
black holes could all of this
entanglement there in this picture could
that have something to do with the fact
that the space is sort of connected up
into one nice smooth empty that's made
universe threads in some sense we call
it the fabric of space is it somehow
threaded in documented to this to this
entanglement then you were able to
mathematically study that by
mathematically cutting the entanglement
lines on the outside right
it's what we call a thought experiment
you just sort of take your take your
math your description of this and you
say well what happens if I cut those
threads of entanglement what happens if
we cut some I take some of the left half
of the hologram and the right half of
the hologram and I remove the
entanglement between those two sides
there's an effect you you remove
entanglement in the hologram and then
the space-time start splitting up and it
you know you can actually imagine even
even more than this that you got a ball
of clay and you're pulling it apart yeah
and it's getting further apart and the
middle is pinching off and and so you
you could keep doing that you say well
what would happen if I took away even
more entanglement and took away even
more entanglement and then in this in
this model you know now you've got your
space and it split into four pieces and
I've still got a little bit of
entanglement but I'm gonna take that
away and what happens in this
description is that the you know the big
nice empty universe that you thought you
were describing just splits up into into
millions of tiny tiny bits and once
you've got no more entanglement there in
this description you've got no more
space-time at all and and so you get to
you know if this is all right you get to
this incredibly dramatic conclusion that
maybe maybe you've just understood what
space actually is and it's actually
fundamentally quantum mechanical that
space is somehow a manifestation of
quantum entanglement in the underlying
hologram system there's this beautiful
possibility that that we may actually
get insight into what holds space itself
together and it may be entanglement in
this holographic description that's
actually threading it all together which
is you know I have to say you know as a
as a graduate student I you know as a
you know you have dreams of the things
that you might one day gain insight into
and certain when I was a graduate
student the idea that we might somehow
understand the fundamental structure of
space itself is one of those
unattainable dreams and the work that
that you guys are doing is is starting
to reveal a possibility that that we may
actually
get there so I'm gonna personally
applaud right here because that is just
you know an absolutely absolutely
stunning insight which puts together all
of these ideas the ideas have
entanglement the ideas of holography all
put together to gain these insights so
so we're sort of out there in the in the
in the in the in the depths of some
pretty heady ideas we're just gonna
spill over for a couple of minutes I
hope that's okay with you because I just
want to sort of pull us back a little
bit to to what quantum mechanics can
actually do in in the in the world
around us that might actually affect the
future of how we do various things so
brigitta you know you you work in the
arena of quantum computing what are the
possibilities of actually harnessing
these weird wonderful ideas in a manner
that could actually have an impact to to
say computing power well so over the
last thirty years there's been a very
rapid growth of the field of quantum
information which is really a marriage
of information science and quantum
mechanics and this is still the quantum
mechanics from the 1930s 1943 don't even
need relativistic effects for this and
what we've seen is in middle 1990s there
was a very dramatic publication of an
algorithm for doing a quantum for doing
a calculation of factoring large numbers
and this was an algorithm due to Peter
shor and this algorithm showed could be
run many many orders of magnitude faster
if you had a machine a computer that was
built on the principles of quantum
mechanics using superposition States
using these wave functions delocalized
highly delocalized wave functions over
many bits and principles of entanglement
and then having having however to
maintain the very delicate quantum
nature of the system and not allowing
interaction with the environment to
happen but if you do this and then at
the end you after many procedures
quantum procedures you would construct a
very carefully designed measurement and
ideally
on one measurement at the end and it
would be the right measurement that
would give you the answer to your
calculation and we do we're gonna
breathe this this was very important
because factoring large numbers lies at
the heart of most of our encryption
schemes the encryption of your credit
cards today and I tickets anything that
you think of and so from that moment on
the incense that sort of the race to
build such a quantum computer and
there's been a lot of advances
experimentally and over the last 20
years and we're now at the point where
we have functioning devices with nine or
ten quantum bits the quantum analog of a
classical bit and in the quantum bit so
as we saw these examples of the spinning
electrons so a classical bit will either
be in a state zero or one
our digital universe which we saw in
outer space just now but the quantum bit
can be in a superposition it can be any
arbitrary superposition of 0 and 1 which
means it will be both 1 or 0 or and at
the same time 1 and 0 it will just
carrying this mystery along with us and
so we now have devices that are
functioning with about 10 of these say
10 10 9 actually the canonical number
right now yeah but people are working
furiously now to build up to about 50 60
and within a few years we should have
somewhere close to 100 and then once we
get close to about a hundred that's a
critical number because at that point
one starts to have real technical
challenges in maintaining the quantum
nature of the states of these machines
and that brings in these issues of the
environment decoherence and also very
very delicate control and if Jared
mentioned you know then you really have
to know many many many many many
variables to really and to control every
one of those variables and that's a
really big dose physics
an engineering problem which is just
starting to be addressed now and then
after that it's very I think it's
impossible to predict how long it would
take after that if at all possible to go
up to about a thousand or so and a
thousand is about the number where one
would really have an arm a machine which
would do things that couldn't be
computed in the lifetime of the universe
on a classical machine so that would be
the real change or information phrasing
so so we're just about at a time but I
wanted to end on even bringing this even
further down to earth because we sort of
sort out the cosmos black holes
wormholes entanglement there's a
wonderful demonstration in which these
quantum mechanical ideas does something
that I find i popping no matter how many
times I've seen it maybe some of you
have seen it before we have our fingers
crossed oh Milan can you come out one
more time with our with quantum
levitation if you would which is a
stunning demonstration of again some of
the the strange ways in which quantum
mechanics allows the world to work in
ways that again a classical intuition
would not expect and omeone does this
free hand I'm gonna stand back and you
want me to actually touch this but I'm
gonna wear a glove he only wears it to
look like he's being responsible I see
him do this with the bare hand all the
time wait you know that's just crazy
that's like 77 degrees or something yeah
Kelvin which is cold okay so let's just
go right to the disk if you would and if
you just put that there and then I'm
gonna give this a little bit of a push
around can you see that up on the can
you get a shot of that this is actually
just hovering and I give it a little bit
more of a push and what's happening here
if you bring up the final slide that we
have it's called quantum locking it was
a wonderful application of quantum ideas
that originated with some Israeli
physicists who demonstrated this once
before you got magnetic lines that are
penetrating this super
conducting disks it's cold that allows
it to be a superconductor and the the
threads of these magnetic lines are able
to in sometimes pin this object along
this track the track has a uniform
magnetic field and as long as you keep
it cold and superconducting they will
hold it in place here's another
illustration of these ideas look at that
can you get a close-up of that shot
right there you can bring that up on the
screen there you go
so you see that's just hovering right
there and there's nothing in between
there and can we actually can we can we
do them can we flip this over and show
how that goes
yeah so we can take this guy and you
want okay and do you want a glove no you
just want to do it by hand there yeah
okay more fun that way he says okay yeah
Wow that's insane okay
now can you get a shot of that
underneath there it is now hovering
underneath which is uh fairly stunning
and yes right down to earth
demonstration of quantum mechanics Oman
thank you so totally cool okay I want to
thank the entire panel for I hope was an
interesting journey David was
whaling mark von Romme duck and you are
too tough
so thank you very much thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]